hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby and i'll be your driver on this
journey uh sorry about the delay getting
started here tonight we had to track
down some equipment but we're up and
running now
and i have good news i won a chess
tournament i won the amateur in premiere
otherwise known as the premier amateur
over the weekends
um and so i wanted to share some of my
more interesting games from that event
because there were some instructive
mistakes going on and i think it's
worthwhile to uh to go through these
games so the one i wanted to start with
is probably the most complex one of of
the event for me i was playing pratik
namali who i think is a high schooler in
the area maybe he just graduated uh and
he's pretty decent he's uh i think
around 2100 uh uscf and fide and he had
the white pieces against me
now critique played the move one e4 and
i went into the carol khan and i sort of
knew what to expect he pretty much
always plays the exchange variation
and then he chose this move knight to f3
so what do you guys think about this
move knight f3 um any exchange caro
aficionados out there
all right thomas dipped his feet what do
you think
what do you think about the move knight
f3
oh and why is that
yeah so bobby fischer was a huge fan of
the exchange caro khan but he would
always play it with a very specific idea
of making it difficult for black to
develop this bishop so you would see
much more often to move bishop d3 from
fischer and now after you know black is
gonna continue development like let's
say knight c6 knight f6 you know maybe
white plays this move bishop f4
and it's not so so easy to develop the
bishop uh sometimes players with the
white pieces will even play the move h3
here just to fully take away all of the
squares for your pieces
now in the game he chose this move
knight f3 and this move order is adopted
by players with the white pieces
sometimes because the move bishop g4 is
still you know slightly uh premature i
would say uh
h3 is has been chosen bishop f4 has been
chosen
um and generally you get this kind of
trade-off where if black gets the bishop
out to g4
white gets the bishop to f4 and makes
playing a the natural developing idea of
bishop d6 a little bit harder because
white got to the diagonal first
so players with the black pieces
generally start with developing one of
the knights which is what i did
and then in my analysis i'd only seen
this move
c3
and now if you go bishop to g4
white has this nice line this nice idea
of going queen to b3 and this is
something you always really want to be
looking out for in any kind of opening
where you move the queen's pawns and
develop the queen side bishop early on
you need to be checking for these ideas
of your light squares being loose on the
queen side if you're black or your dark
square is being loose if you're white
you see the b2 pawn b week the b7 pawn b
weak this diagonal can also end up being
weak
so i had you know seen this position
before and i was intending to play this
move queen to c7
so what's going on with queen to c7 why
would black potentially choose this move
over the move bishop g4
yeah tom
stop bishop f4 the natural developing
idea yeah to stop bishop f4 uh so that
is what i sort of planned going in and
to be honest i didn't do much prep
beyond that it's an exchange caro khan
you sort of know what's going to be
going on you can play with the ideas
but my opponent sort of surprised me
with the move bishop d3 i hadn't checked
this move specifically
and it turns out that against this move
probably black should play bishop to g4
now of course why is bishop g4 better
here than it was in the other position
any ideas
no queen b3 it's that simple
so you already see it's moved like four
or five but some pretty serious mistakes
have already been made by by both
players so it's really important to
understand these nuances step by step as
far as what's going on in these uh early
opening moves and why you know the the
mainline move orders are the way they
are it's really helpful to understand
these differences and that's going to
help you get the most from your openings
now
um i sort of had my plan going in and i
didn't really think much about bishop d3
because there's still nothing wrong with
with queen c7 so i chose this line
anyways but perhaps a little bit of a
missed opportunity uh with this move
bishop to g4 now very quickly my
opponent played the move h3 saying i'm
not going to give you a second chance
you know the
your your chance to come to g4 is is
gone
so now
uh black to move how do you want to
develop your pieces there's
really two different setups you can you
can adopt here maybe even three setups
you can go for
what do you think
and then put your bishop on g7
yeah this is a plan that i've i've
actually played quite often uh however
there's a particular reason why maybe
it doesn't make quite as much sense here
and that reason is we've spent a tempo
with queen to c7
so with this move we're very distinctly
saying
we want to control this diagonal and
that's the diagonal we want to put our
bishop on
now if we wanted to play like that we
could do so here
we could play knight f6 let's say
h3 anyways g6 bishop f4
bishop g7
and now we don't really mind this bishop
on f4 because you know we weren't
putting our bishop there anyways so
uh because of that while this is one of
the main ways to to set up your pieces i
didn't want to go for it here so i've
already chosen queen c7 i've sort of
made that choice against that setup
already
so how else how else do we finish your
development
not a trick question what are the normal
looking moves
knight f6 and you want to go for e5
uh with bishop d6 yeah
right so maybe
you know your opponent gets castled
first maybe you're not quite ready to
play e5 just yet though right
uh because you know e5 it can get
captured and your opponent's rook is in
the center your king is in the center
you still haven't castled gonna look a
little bit a little bit scary for you
right
in fact i think tactically here you know
this is already big danger big danger
maybe not lost but but but dangerous
so i didn't really want to go for that
so now instead you can choose the move
e6
um and let's just say normal moves you
can go bishop d6
but long term what what's the issue here
what's the issue with this setup
yeah the light squared bishop
so we can sort of think ahead and and
form a plan here we know that uh
we know normal ways to set up our pieces
but eventually we have to do something
with this bishop so your idea was to
eventually play e5 and i like this idea
however
in the long term let's say you know we
get a few free moves let's say white
sort of doesn't do much plays c3 we can
play e5 but it's going to leave us with
a structural weakness right what's the
structural weakness when you play e5
isolated
yeah it's going to leave you with the
isilani here and perhaps this is going
to give white some some kind of small
plus if
we have to deal with our isolated pawn
so
i'm going to claim that there is a
better way of going about this e5 plan a
better way to set up our other pieces to
help support this plan
don't tell me f6
well yeah it is f6 but you're not going
to play f6 first
so we want to develop our pieces such
that we can go f6 e5
so we're actually going to start with
the move e6 it's going to look very
normal
my opponent played c3 we go bishop d6
castles and then the key here is what we
do with with our king side knight so of
course rather than put it on f6 where
we're going to put our pawn it can come
to e7
so now
it helps support the center we have the
long term plan of f6 e5 breaking through
the center and again let me just put
some nonsense moves on the board
knight f1 let's say eventually we get e5
now of course we're not leaving
ourselves with a weakness
because we have a central pawn duo which
is much much better than the isolated
pawn which can be weak and get attacked
so that's the the long-term planning
going on in the early stages of the game
here
so this all happened in the game i go
knight ge7 and my opponent plays rook to
e1
now what move do you want to play here
just automatically
castles is automatic
but what happens if you play castles
automatically
yes so that that's the question right
so
uh of course
by virtue of not putting this knight on
the most natural square of f6 we've left
our king's side a little bit more
vulnerable
but that being said the greek gift
doesn't work all the time right it
doesn't work all the time brian knows
brian who's in the audience today had a
game where his opponent did a very bad
greek gift sacrifice and was just down a
piece
so let's try to calculate can you castle
is bishop takes h7 working that's your
first problem to solve of the game
everything else you know i i sort of
knew going in i knew i wanted to put my
knight on e7 i was going to play for
this plan
uh but this was my my first problem to
solve over the board so let's pose the
challenge to you
one vote for never works
so let's start with the obvious
okay let's put it on the board takes
takes
knight g5 can you play the move king g8
here
no why not
diagonal
right you can't cover it at all
so whenever this sacrifice happens uh
the only way that you get away with it
is if after queen h5 you know somehow
you can either bring a knight to f6 to
defend you can bring a bishop to the
diagonal or a queen to the diagonal
you need some way to cover this h7
square
really no other way to get out you can
try to move your rook
but this will happen to you first
and this is just no fun
um
i'm gonna fail to find checkmate
immediately but no fun
so
of course we have to go up so can we go
to h6
obviously not because our opponent has
this really strong attacking piece on c1
we would lose a queen immediately
so your challenge is to calculate what
happens after king g6 that's what's
going to tell you if black can get away
with castling here and i'm going to be
really mean and make you look from this
position and you saw the move that i
played in the game but hopefully that
doesn't reveal the answer
so can you castle
or is king g6 not enough to defend your
king
and if you're gonna tell me that you're
allowed to castle you have to tell me
what your defense is those are the rules
and if you're going to tell me that i
can't castle you have to tell me what
the winning line for white is
because if you can castle probably you
should
what do you think nate
let's say you can castle okay
so how do you defend
all right i was thinking
after
king the g6
yep i thought his best move was
i agree queen g4 definitely looks like
the most testing idea and then i thought
i would play s6 and try and
have my king run through f7 f6 okay so
i'm gonna let you know i think you lose
your queen in that variation
so let's let's put it on the board so
you're correct you have the main
position in mind so knight g5 we know
that these moves don't work we know that
this move doesn't work so king g6
and then you're right in thinking that
queen to g4 is really the the only
really relevant variation if he checks
you somewhere else
you just go f5
and you you're going to be running away
to safety right no way to get after this
king now
if you play something slow
like i don't know rook e3 then you're
going to play f6 and like you said
you're going to run with your king to f7
but queen g4 actually prevents the move
f6 because we have this discovered
attack on your king
so queen g4 you need something better
f5 but of course you don't stop
calculating just when you attack your
opponent's queen what does white do
whoa whoa 96
we take
i got i got two guys
yeah
i got two guys so 96 not good enough
yeah queen h4 of course
and i got this far in my head this is
where i got
and i was thinking and i was thinking
and i wasn't 100 sure
so it turns out black does have a good
move here and is just winning but i
wasn't able to find it in my head during
the game
so i'll give you guys a chance
it's not at all obvious at least not to
me
yeah you can put him in check but he'll
move
and then all the same problems are still
here right
we'll look from here
yeah it looks looks kind of tough right
how am i gonna get my king out i'm i'm
blocked over here
you know my opponent
is threatening at least one check and
maybe there's nothing after the check
but still looks scary right
so all right do you guys give up i i
gave up in the game
bishop d7 yeah i'm not scared
bishop d7 might be okay
um
did you consider this move yes
my idea is
queen c8
okay i'm gonna
i i'm gonna do any number of things my
goodness
take your rook with check take your guy
okay okay okay
i missed queen g5 we're gonna pretend
like i never said that okay bishop d7
might honestly be okay for you um takes
you can take
this is the only takes
you have rook f6 right but the only
thing
you know i was thinking in my head
there's there's stuff there's like takes
and like other stuff and
you know other stuff
wasn't so sure turns out there's a
really really clean move here and that
move is f4
tough to find the idea is really simple
you want to bring your king your
knight's in the way so you want to move
your knight
so you move your knight here
and if queen back to g4
we go king f6 do we go king f6
no we go king h6 that's that's right and
wait never mind that's a draw never mind
f4 queen g4 i i like still don't see the
idea
you play e5
are you sure
yeah
maybe maybe this is
another this is probably correct
actually this is probably the line and
you pick up the knight but uh pretty
tough right
pretty tough
so
i have this position in my head i'm like
i need to make it so i have a really
clean defense in this position
right so what move would be really
really great if you know it didn't hang
a rook
well ricket [ __ ] would be amazing it
would be winning a queen if it didn't
hang a rook
so
in this position what move do you guys
want to play
that's what i wanted to play
so there you go that's how you arrive at
the move bishop d7 you want to castle
you're worried about this line so you
have to decide how can i make it so this
line is not so scary and the answer is
bishop to d7 my opponent played knight b
or my opponent played a4
i castled
um
now my opponent thought forever
uh and he was i'm pretty sure he was
just calculating exactly what we just
looked at so we'll go to the same
position
and of course
there's rook h8
and absolutely nothing doing for white
in fact white is is just dead lost
so there you go we solved our first
problem of the game we managed to castle
and avoid dying to the greek gift gold
star
so my opponent thought forever played
knight b to d2 and here comes my first
big mistake
so
um
i was aware of a number of plans here
for the player with the white pieces
um surprisingly there's this slightly
counter-intuitive move c4 that can
occasionally be very occasionally be
very strong
the reason being our bishop is quite bad
and white is uh you know willing to
accept this weakness on d4 in order to
jump in with the knight start targeting
our pieces while you know we've slightly
misplaced them right our knight on e7
looks slightly weird
and the white pieces are jumping in but
the c4 ideas is normally not not so
scary um white actually has a couple
other
pretty dangerous ways to play so what
happened in the game was my opponent
just played normally he played like
knight f1 develops his pieces tried to
checkmate me just normal stuff
but there is a very concrete way uh that
i i thought white was threatening
threatening to play here so let's say
i play some move so i play f6
uh i'm gonna
give you guys whiplash white white to
move here what what kind of ideas are
you looking at
i just literally want to play
so why do you want to play b4 i'm all
about that space
all about that space okay so well i mean
what's what's the follow-up what are you
doing
playing b5
right away
okay so you want to go b4 b5 knight b3
knight c5 so
all is well let's put b4 on the board
let's say i play some normal move
knight b3
so why knight b3 instead of b5
well because
well there's there's something wrong
with with b5
yeah knight a5 is very very nice for for
black so whenever you're expanding on
the queen side like this you don't
really want to give away those those
kinds of squares
um but i i totally agree with you i was
i was worried about b4 now it turns out
in this position b4 is is not so so
scary for black it's it's just fine it's
one of the ideas for white it's a fine
idea for white but it's not so scary so
uh how can black kind of deal with this
i think you can actually play a5 here
now b5 is sort of uh necessary
and after something like knight to b3
you're not actually coming to the square
just yet and i think i'm gonna be in
time to organize my pieces
and find counter play of my own
so we we get this sort of fight on the
queen side
and i wasn't super happy with allowing
this okay so whiplash again look out
so what move do you think i played here
yeah a5 just stopping the idea before i
have to worry about it
um but it turns out there's a a really
funny idea here for white so just to
remind you of the game knight bd2 a5
yeah
so
uh the only way to try to play for an
edge with white here is to come back
um really hard to do if you're you're
playing over the board to develop your
knight and then undevelop your night so
of course the downside to a5 is that it
has allowed a weakness on the the b5
square
he did not play this
i've been i've been like literally
crushed like
this like this
yeah i mean you kind of have to do it
quickly like i'm doing active things on
the other side of the board if you do
this
do you play like knight d8s like let's
say your
it and you play like f6 98 75 or
something
i have no idea we're talking about like
okay so like if they like don't play
knight v1 for example
okay
knight f1 was played in the game yeah do
you like time to play d8 f6
knight f75
or is that just like way too crazy
very weird to move the knight to d8 and
then f7 so we we have our idea our idea
is f6 e5 so i'm on board with you there
but uh
this knight is well placed it controls
the center it pressures white's center
we don't need to move this knight you
know all over the place but
um yeah but that that's what i was uh
intending in the game uh so my opponent
played knight to f1 again let's move
knight to b1 maybe maybe gave me some
problems um so knight to f1 instead much
a much more you know
human way i would say to approach it you
know maybe you spot this idea hard to
convince yourself it's good after you
play the move knight to d2
so i continue out now with with f6
opponent went back with bishops to c2 so
he's giving us another problem so
everybody and their grandmother
hopefully knows what white's next move
is
right
yeah queen d3 we've seen this one before
we've seen this one before
so
how do you want to stop it
i mean i want to play
i
yeah that would be ideal that would be
ideal for sure
so it's um
it's
flimsy but if it works you should
actually play this so you have to
calculate concretely that e5 doesn't
work unfortunately for us it it does not
white takes
to allow the queen to attack then we get
pinned
that's the second attacker we only have
one way to defend this pawn
and then white attacks it again pawn is
still pinned we just very concretely
lose a pawn here
so e5 would be the ideal solution for us
but we calculate it doesn't work gotta
do something else
so
this is the idea that i came up with in
the game i wanted to go knight g6
and uh defend my king
now in the game i thought it was smart
to start with this move rook f to e8
so why do you think i thought that this
was smart what was i worried about if we
go knight g6 right away
yeah sometimes white actually takes this
knight
and this structure is really bad it's
really not good and why is it so not
good well we have our plan in the
position we want to play e5 and so let's
say i pass
we want to play e5 take with the pawn
and have a big center
now we do get our big center but
g6 g7
kinda kind of suffering for for our king
so i thought it would be a good idea
to play this move first
wait for the move queen d3
and then come with knight g6
to f8 never giving my opponent the
chance to capture me and that's actually
what happened in the game
however
i do think that
white again had sort of a more concrete
plan here in the game my opponent
started to kind of stumble and and
couldn't come up with something active
to do just sort of gave me a free hand
and then we'll see that eventually the
the plan of e5 comes through but here
once again white could have found
something active to do
this time on the king's side rather than
the queen side
so wait to move here
see if you can find some way to get
black problems
brent
just said h4 so that normally means the
pawn
so
all right tom is playing like my
opponent opponent played knight h4
this was all according to plan this is
why i moved the rook i wanted to tuck my
knight away on f8
now
pawn h4 might actually give me some more
problems so what what's the idea what's
the idea brian
okay
uh let's say i go knight f8 are you i'll
do it voluntarily do you still want h5
okay h5
i
will keep calm play some
moves and then i'll play
so h6 is is the right idea um knight h4
first actually helps me um
so i'm actually going to play a better
move the night 97 i'm gonna play rookie
seven
and now the problem is after h6 black's
best move might be somewhat surprising
to you but black is actually going to go
g5 so this is why knight h4 is sort of
not not ideal because you would just
lose a tempo on on the main line
um
and the thing is now
you know the the
pace of the game is is being more
dictated by by white right with with
this h4h5 h6 idea it provokes a ton of
weaknesses in my king's side in fact so
many weaknesses it's going to be really
tough to play the move e5 and open
things up on this side of the board for
me now so instead the game's going to
take you know maybe a slower approach
might continue out with knight to g6 to
follow
and sort of play for more
positional ideas control over the the f4
square for example and maybe actually
jacob's idea of knight knight d8 to f7
makes a lot more sense now since we have
a target over here on h6
but with this idea white could have
effectively kind of taken more control
over the game would have
been dictating the pace of the game
which objectively makes a small amount
of difference white's position is better
here than it is in the main line but
especially practically and
psychologically that's that's sort of a
huge deal if you're stopping your
opponent's plan and they're having to
like change their ideas and you're you
know you feel like you're in control it
it actually becomes a lot easier to find
your moves in in my experience so i
think that was a little bit of a missed
opportunity by pratik and said he played
knight h4 i just dropped back with
knight to f8 uh of course the tactical
justification is if i capture
uh he takes the knight back plus the
pawn
so i come back to f8
and now my opponent realized uh he had
nothing to do
so we've locked him down on the queen
side with our a5 pawn we've successfully
avoided being trackmated by force on the
king's side he did not find this idea of
pushing the pawn forward
and he put his knight on the side of the
board so critique thought for for quite
a while here and played knight back to
f3 which you know
in hindsight maybe knight h4 not the
best idea right just knight h4 to f3
doesn't make a ton of sense um
i came back with knight to e7 so why do
you think this move was was my choice
i'm improving my pieces i'm preparing
for the e5 break so what what setup am i
going for
it might come to g6
think of the problems with e5
and think of how i can best position my
pieces to meet those problems
what are the problems with e5
my d5 pawn is weak and sometimes my e5
pawn is weak
so how
how can i bring all of my pieces into
the game to help defend these two pawns
where do my pieces belong that's the
question
no the knife
is maybe that knight on e7 stays there
but now
you're
defending both of the squares
simultaneously so they're
so what i'm saying is there are two
important squares for you to control
when you play the move e5 two of the
most important squares are of course d5
and e5 those are the squares you need to
absolutely have under control because
that's where your your pawn center is
going to be and you need to have more
control than your opponent otherwise
your opponent will capture one of your
pawns and your whole plan falls apart
so
um that's why we started with this move
knight to e7 because it's a little bit
awkward to defend the d5 pawn so this
knight gets involved now our knight on
f8 is already actually pretty good here
it's defending our king and it's you
know allowing us to reposition our other
pieces by by defending our other weak
pawn so the idea is not necessarily
knight to g6 we'll see that maybe later
on that'll make sense but but not yet
now we talked a lot about the knights a
little bit about the bishops but we want
to involve the rooks as well right so
how do we make it so the rooks can be
useful
i'm not so worried about the c file
though i i need d5 and e5 these are the
squares
yeah so you bring the rook uh what'd you
say
yep that's what i thought so rook 88
absolutely that's where this rook
belongs
but then you run into this problem where
these files are a little bit clogged
right so how how can the rooks be useful
as yasser says we need to invite
everyone to the party
bishop c6 was the key move that i was
hoping you guys could find
um so bishop c6 is
uh sort of really ideal for us
so with knight to e7 we're preparing to
bring our bishop to c6 where it's both
defending our center and preparing to
attack after we move the center puns
even further it's also um we'll see 93
in the game it's also unclogging the d
file
allowing our rook to
play in the game and we'll see it's even
clearing up a very useful square for our
queen on d7
so that's that's the setup so our
opponent is doing nothing he gave up on
finding a plan he's just moving around
bishop d2 bishop c6 rook c1 queen d7
and suddenly now
first of all we made a threat over here
second of all we have two major pieces
ready to help defend our d-pawn we have
our bishop placed on c6 already
defending the center and even further
we have our other bishop ready to defend
the center and we have our knight you
know well placed to defend d5 and also
the the newly weakened f5 square after
we push forward and so
suddenly you know we go from this where
e5 sort of seems like a pipe dream how
are you ever going to defend your pawns
enough but once you reposition you bring
everybody to the party
then
you have the control that you need
so with queen d7 we made a threat
so my opponent played b3 defending the
a4 pawn and now
the question is should we play e5 or can
we improve our position even further
and i'll give you a hint i chose wrong
in the game
big hints
if
this one
so
perhaps it might make sense to bring
this knight out actually but this knight
on on e7 is actually helping us control
d5 and that's kind of a more important
than e5 we have a lot of control over e5
not quite as much
over e5
yep
right that's what i thought
so i thought
you know i i thought there was no rush i
thought we could play bishop c7 how does
this improve our position well no
there's actually nothing in the way of
our major pieces defending our d-pawn
and i thought i could just play slowly
and then get e5 e4 this nice leisurely
pl pace and uh and play some chess
um
now it turns out that this isn't quite
as strong as playing e5 just directly
now we we have everything defended
there's actually no way that white can
really even threaten to take our pawns
after takes takes
we open things up we're ready to push
through with e4 white's in big big
trouble already you know you have to
play awkward moves like queen to f1 to
get out of the way of this idea um
something like knight to f5 i think is
actually just gonna lose a piece
immediately like you just can't play
actively here with white and it's big
big trouble big big trouble
so should i just played e5 i played
slowly instead with bishop dc7
my opponent played knight to f1 which
now of course is stopping e5 because
while we do have d5 defended a billion
times e5 is now the weak point
so
back to chess we uh i i did bring the
knight uh from
e7 to g6 now like you were suggesting
actually and the reason is our opponent
dropped this knight back no longer
attacking this guy and we opened these
guys up so now it does make sense to to
bring him over we don't need him on d5
so we use them over here instead
my opponent played knight to g3
and here again i can go e5 the move i
played is also actually very good for
for black uh just came in with knight f4
so just playing slowly i have this e5
plan whenever i want it and i'm just
trying to misplace my opponent's pieces
a little bit further
opponent came back with queen to f1
i bring out my other knight just trying
to slowly but surely push forward get
ready for for e5
my opponent played uh knight to e2
now i come out with queen to d6 so again
just improving my pieces to the maximum
before we break through
now my opponent plays g3 he's worried
about these types of ideas
remember when it was our opponent
threatening that now it's us so he goes
g3
take take and finally finally finally
it's time for e5
um so i play it
and
uh we you know there's no other way
really to improve the pieces further so
i decided it was finally time turns out
i had one or two moments before this
even to play e5 as i mentioned but doing
it here
also very strong
so remember earlier when i talked about
how this pawn structure was super bad
it's still true
but in this case we have the bishop pair
we have our pieces on pretty much ideal
squares supporting the center of pawns
ready to push them further down the
board and because of that black is is
doing doing very very well
now my opponent is a very practical and
tricky player and he said i don't care
about your center i'm going to come
check main chute
so knight g5 and we have our our next
mistake of the game by by me
so what is our opponent doing
how is he coming to get us
yeah so queen f3 is is not quite enough
we we have rooks ready to step to the f
file to defend us queen g4 is a little
bit threatening
um 96 not really going to be a big
problem though we have e6 well defended
so what's the idea
it's just not really feasible here you
gave up your light squared bishop so
this f7 square you know i have all my
major pieces here i can defend it in
eight different ways right
but queen g4 comes with another threat
f4
no no no no no don't go psycho don't go
psycho
yeah queen h4 that's exactly right it's
very simple right
back to the h7 square it's the same
check mating pattern we've we've seen
before
but this time now i'm out of nights to
help defend my king no more nights on fa
right no more no more safety
so
the question is how much do you care
about that plan right if you don't care
about that plan you can keep going in
the center if you do care about that
plan it might be worth a tempo to slow
it down or stop it all together
so what do you think that's that's the
new the new question
and it's the next question that i i got
wrong during the game
exactly that is the best move
queen g4 turns out to be a pretty
dangerous threat uh one that i kind of
underestimated during the game
uh and so it's very useful here to just
take some time play queen to d7
stop queen to g4 if your opponent tries
to attack you some other way go queen to
f5
say what are you doing i have i have
control over the position i have the
center i have the bishops you know i i
can again go back to playing slowly
take some time to defend my king and
then and then move on and here black is
again just doing very very very well
um now in the game no respect for queen
g4 i said i am going to break through in
the center and checkmate you on the
light squares because you gave me your
lights great bishop my opponent said go
ahead and try
i said okay i'll try he said just
kidding don't do it
um
and this was all correct
now i took on c3 i need to open the
position up activate my pieces while
while he's trying to checkmate me
you know uh i've made some weaknesses
around my king but so so has white of
course and my opponent found this really
good move actually bishop to e3 in the
game i i didn't really expect this but
turns out this bishop is very very
dangerous on the e3 square not so
dangerous on the c3 square
so
this is where i thought for the longest
during the game and a little bit of a
note on time management
in the game my opponent had i think five
or less five or fewer minutes here
within five minutes of of running out of
time i had 40 minutes on my clock i
believe
and whenever that's the case
who knows the best way
to manage your time
in a complicated complicated position
you're up more than half an hour your
opponent has very little time what's the
best way to put on pressure
okay take all your time but how do you
want to spend it
do you want to like slowly over the
course the next few moves
well yeah how do you spend your time
i spend my time
okay so i'm sorry
giving some leading questions that
turned out to be misleading so
the best way in my opinion uh to spend
your time in this kind of situation is
to spend all of your time up front you
want to calculate as much as you can
here be as sure as you can up front
because your opponent doesn't know what
you're going to play
they don't know what you're calculating
you have a ton of options here as black
and if you figure out as much as you can
from here
then
you you feel like you know everything
you surprise your opponent somewhere
along the way
um or get surprised if you know you
didn't calculate as well as you thought
uh and then you're really putting on the
pressure on the clock so here i thought
for a very very long time probably went
down to around 15 minutes
maybe i had a bit more than 15 but then
i played queen b3
and now the second half of this is that
after white plays the obvious move queen
to h4
uh you continue playing quickly right
you've calculated the line you want to
keep the pressure on him so he doesn't
have time to find the best move in any
of these positions
um
and that's how you can use your time
really effectively to get a good
position
so here
i actually played the wrong move though
played rook to d7
now rook to d7 is very nearly the best
move rook d3 is the best move
so what's the idea with either of these
moves the idea is that my king needs a
path to safety on the queen's side that
path doesn't really exist going this way
in front of the rook
for reasons that that we will see namely
because queen f5 happens
but it does exist
in this case now here my opponent missed
his only chance to uh
to be better
only chance to be better
so take a second try to find it
sort of sort of an impossible task in
the remaining time we have in the class
but
it's worth thinking about
so i will give you a hint
or what do you think eric
no i'll give you a hint
what is black playing after queen h7
queen h8
oh so you play
bishop
that's what eric thought but hold on
what are we doing here
you want to go king e7
but king e7 i think is is going to be
dangerous right it's going to be a
little bit dangerous at least
um
let me take a moment make sure i'm
not doing things horribly horribly wrong
maybe you can play king e7 but still
going to be dangerous right bishop c5
you can come this way i guess
interesting
let me do this first bishop c5 bishop d6
now queen h8
you can still come here
but there's this
your rook hangs right
so
this line is a problem
uh if black doesn't have the move that
black has here
queen g8 right so queen g8 in many many
lines but most particularly this one is
is the key defensive resource
um and now in my head i had seen all of
this you can still get my e5 pawn but
this time my rook is defended defended
by my queen
black is winning
so
white's winning try
involves
getting rid of this queen g8 defensive
idea
rook b1 is exactly correct and if i go
queen a2
rook a1 and if queen b3
rook e b1 and if queen d5
rook d1 and
this is what i had miss evaluated
here i thought black would be close to
winning
turns out white is slightly better
yeah so my evaluation of this position
was was just wrong um turns out these
threats
way too strong black has to give up
material
and
maybe i hold this end game maybe i don't
i don't know maybe i don't even find her
d2
tough to say i didn't analyze too deeply
but that was that was his only chance
instead he played queen h7 very quickly
because he had no time on his clock
played king f8 played queen g6
played bishop to b6
not falling for checkmate
that would not have been
ideal literal checkmate
so we pin the bishop
and now he has to go queen f5 and turns
out chess is a draw
instead he played knight h7 very quickly
because he had no time
go king e7 check
surprised him here i came up the board
uh rather than coming back which was
worse for some reason which i'm already
forgetting let's not get bogged down in
the details
check back takes takes queen h6
and at the end of the day
once our king survives our c pawn also
survives and the sea pawn is is gonna
win the day for black here the game
continued without much controversy there
was knight f8 which was a tricky move
but by this point my king is safe enough
i always have resources multiple
resources to defend
stepped out of all the pins
invaded with the rook
invaded with the queen
and then there's one nice little
flourish to end the game there's queen
c5 check king a6 queen c4 check king b6
if you take my bishop this is checkmate
queen e6
and i triangulate my king
and then there's no more checks
opponent came back took the rook
now i can triangulate again
but instead i go bishop b5 my opponent
resigns
so very very complicated game and a lot
to talk about in the early middle game
this is where uh really i i think all
all the action happens that's where my
opponent and i spent most of our time
and then eventually i found a good
moment to break through even if the
follow-ups were perhaps less than ideal
um
so a lot of important things to keep in
mind here um
there's sort of this saying that a bad
plan is better than no plan at all i
don't really agree with it but in this
case you know white had numerous options
to find an active plan to help uh change
the pace of the game you know knight b1
in this case active plan
um
h4 in this case another active plan
and after that
i think even here white could have again
tried to do something like b4 get active
again i think i skipped over this in the
lecture for the sake of time but
numerous options for white to try to get
active try to fight back in the game and
instead sort of did nothing
let me do whatever i wanted with my
pieces
and slowly but surely broke with e5 and
black should have been much much better
but you know then then the chess game
happens and
the rest is history so any questions
about this game
it was a pretty dense game
so it makes sense if you did have
questions
nothing at all
so this position is like
an engine evaluation like minus point
two submission is like plus point five
so it's a pretty big swing
um so what do you wanna do here with
black just for the sake of argument
oh i
oh you want to take all right
um yeah i think white's just gonna take
with with the bishop
um
well
the outpost is is not so important but
your light squared bishop will will
actually be missed in this position
long term
you're going to want that guy
um
because again now it becomes difficult
to find an active plan for black right
your plan revolved around opening up the
center
but now opening up the center is likely
going to be favoring the bishops because
they're bishops they like open positions
and and so without that i mean i think
it's a small plus for white i don't
think black is like lost but uh i think
white is a bit better what were you
gonna do
i didn't see it
just didn't see it
i don't know what would you do now uh
yeah i mean your idea seems reasonable
your idea seems
reasonable uh
i might do
something that looks even more awkward
uh which
is
god it's it's not so easy it's not so
easy i might even just do do something
ridiculous looking like rook c8
from all the way back
and
do something similar similar to the game
now just with with my opponent having a
knight on b5 instead of a knight on f1
pretty big improvement right on b5
versus knight on f1 but
the same plan i think still still holds
here
um and yeah maybe honestly giving up the
bishop not so bad
um okay
that i think is gonna just about do it
for me sorry we only got through one
game but it was it was a complicated
game hopefully you guys enjoyed maybe
i'll go over some more games uh in the
coming weeks there were a lot of fun
ones this tournament
um if you are just tuning in uh be sure
to stay tuned for uni esky quesada our
grand master in residence i believe it
is it's his final day here so stick
around while he's here he's one of the
best uh hopefully you guys enjoy his
lecture and as always my name is caleb
denby thank you very much for coming and
i will see you guys next week
[Music]
you